[Aplausos]
qué es lo primero que se le viene a la
mente cuando escuchan la palabra
depresión
quiero que retengan esa palabra en su
cabeza porque la vamos a ocupar al final
cuando escuchan la palabra lepra
probablemente su cerebro la asocia
inmediatamente con cosas negativas la
lepra es una enfermedad que data desde
miles de años antes de cristo pero que
se descubre su origen y causa hasta 1873
casi 4.000 años después y se descubre
que es una enfermedad crónica bacteriana
de la piel y que afecta a los nervios de
las manos y de los pies y se descubre
también contrario a lo que se creía que
es una enfermedad muy poco contagiosa
sin embargo adivinen que la
desinformación sobre su contagio siguió
la discriminación para quienes padecían
de lepra aumento y el aislamiento para
los enfermos empeoró
la depresión es una enfermedad que se
parece muchísimo a la lepra de aquel
entonces también data de miles de años
atrás y de hecho desde el antiguo egipto
empiezan a asociar a las enfermedades
mentales completado tal y como pasaba en
la lepra de aquel entonces
y las mismas tres cosas que aquejaban a
las personas que padecían de lepra en
aquel entonces son las mismas tres cosas
que aquejan a las personas que padecen
depresión hoy en día
quiero contarles la historia de una mía
esta amiga como la ven sonriente en la
foto estaba pasando por una de sus
mejores etapas estaba delicada estaba
cerca de dios tenía un trabajo el cual
se sentía plena y lo amaba y se sentía
realizada y me acuerdo que hasta ese año
la mandaron a llamar para que modelará
para una ropa de marca ante los ojos
externos mi amiga estaba pasando una
época bomba
pero por dentro mi amiga estaba
sufriendo la mayor depresión que jamás
en su vida había sentido mi amiga empezó
a tener pensamientos auto destructivos
que se convirtieron en actos auto
destructivos y mi amiga tuvo dos
intentos de suicidio
es amiga soy yo
y porque yo he pasado por depresión
ahora me dedico a ayudar a la gente que
también ha pasado por esta condición y a
incentivarlos a continuar con su vida y
porque yo he pasado por esto quiero
pedirles a todos ustedes que me ayuden a
cambiar la realidad para las personas
que padecen de depresión porque sé que
en este salón sólo hay conmigo personas
que son agentes de cambio
hay muchísima esa información sobre qué
es la depresión
hay personas que creen que es un
sentimiento o que es un estado de ánimo
también hay desinformación sobre su
causa hay personalidades propensas a
pasar de depresión o es que soy débil y
no sé afrontar los problemas del día a
día y como creo esto también hay
desinformación sobre el tratamiento
porque si es un problema de personalidad
entonces se puede curar leyendo un libro
de automotivación verdad
miren si ustedes creen esto no se
preocupen aún hay esperanza yo también
pensaba esto años atrás
hay discriminación cuántos de ustedes
estarían dispuestos a iniciar una
relación con una persona a la que le
acaban de diagnosticar trastorno
depresivo mayor el estado más avanzado y
grave de la depresión y cuántos de
ustedes contratarían a una persona en su
equipo de trabajo que ustedes sepan que
tiene depresión
déjenme contarles una historia sumamente
vergonzosa hace un par de años una de
mis mejores amigas y perdón amiga por
contar esto en público te prometo que es
para fines educativos me contó que un
compañero de trabajo con el que tenía
una entrega de un proyecto le escribió
un par de días antes del proyecto
diciéndole algo así disculpa que no
puede acompañarte para la entrega
pero me acaban de diagnosticar trastorno
depresivo mayor y me dieron un mes de
incapacidad
nuestra reacción fue no es que fuera por
buscarlo pero qué falta de
profesionalismo y responsable
ustedes creen que nosotros hubiéramos
reaccionado de la misma manera si esta
persona le hubiera dicho a una amiga que
la acababan de diagnosticar con una
enfermedad física grave les apuesto que
no y les apuesto que esta persona
después vídeo discriminación en su
trabajo por haber contado esto
aislamiento aquí se crea un círculo
vicioso tanto la sociedad aísla la
persona con depresión como la persona
con depresión se aísla de la sociedad si
lo vemos a nivel micro a nivel
individual muchas veces nosotros sin
darnos cuenta cometemos pequeños actos
de aislamiento para las personas que
padecen de depresión como por ejemplo
dejar de invitar a mi amiga la que sé
que tiene depresión a las fiestas o
dejar de tomar en cuenta a mis
compañeros de trabajo para ciertas
actividades laborales tal y como
probablemente pasó en el ejemplo
anterior y si lo vemos a nivel macro a
nivel país en el hospital psiquiátrico
del salvador el único hospital
psiquiátrico público del país según la
oms los ingresados viven en condiciones
precarias y también se cometen faltas en
contra de los derechos humanos y según
la misma o ms el 35 por ciento de las
personas que ingresaron
en contra de su voluntad y el 8% fueron
sometidos a fuerza física o aislamiento
pero no le diera el panorama completo si
no le dijera que también las personas
que padecen de depresión tienden a
aislarse de la sociedad por la misma
sintomatología de la enfermedad
y ahora se preguntarán qué hacemos laura
con estas tres cosas espantosas y
negativas pues las combatimos con tres
cosas positivas primero con educación yo
doy charlas entera sobre esto pero voy a
tratar de resumir lees los principales
puntos que para mí la gente necesita
refuerzo de conocimiento primero debemos
saber que la depresión es una sumatoria
de genética biología eventos reales y
circunstancias hay personas a las que
les va a pesar más su factor hereditario
y hay otras personas que simplemente han
pasado por una serie de eventos y de
circunstancias tan trágicas que la
respuesta natural del cuerpo es
deprimirse
algunas personas necesitan medicamentos
y otras no no se trata de que algunas
personas son más débiles y otros son más
fuertes se trata de producción de
químicos en el cerebro
las personas con depresión no están en
un periodo depresivo todo el tiempo tal
y como pasa con las enfermedades físicas
alguien con diabetes por ejemplo no
tiene su azúcar su vida todo el tiempo
lo mismo pasa con las enfermedades
mentales dependerá mucho de si la
persona está en terapia si está tomando
los medicamentos adecuados si ha tenido
un factor detonante que le pueda
desembocar en una crisis o si
simplemente su salud de balancea
tal y como pasa con las enfermedades
físicas planear el suicidio o tener
intentos de suicidio es un grado de
depresión avanzado y requiere de ayuda
urgente e inmediata y no todas las
personas con depresión llegan a este
extremo
existen diferentes grados y tipos de
depresión y son los psiquiatras quienes
son los encargados de darnos un
diagnóstico y decirnos qué tan avanzadas
está nuestra enfermedad
segundo lo combatimos con empatía tanto
para con nosotros mismos como para con
los demás
miren si nos sacamos de la cabeza que
depresión igual a tristeza
créanme que de manera automática vamos a
dejar de darle consejos a la gente que
padece de depresión porque comparar tus
días tristes con lo que siente una
persona con depresión es como comparar
una llaga en una persona sana con una
llaga en un leproso
y con nosotros mismos si sos tú quien
está padeciendo depresión quiero pedirte
que en primer lugar busques ayuda y en
segundo lugar no te juzgues muchas veces
nos juzgamos más nosotros de lo que
juzgamos a los demás quiero pedirte que
seas tu mejor amigo que te hable con
palabras de amor cuando fue la última
vez que te dijiste te quiero quiero
pedirte que tengas pensar que sustituía
tus pensamientos automáticos
autodestructivos por pensamientos
racionales positivos
tercero con acompañamiento muchas
personas me preguntan la hora como
acompaña a un ser querido que padece de
depresión
he aprendido tres cosas principales en
estos últimos años primero necesitamos
hacer contacto real no es lo mismo un
mensaje por whatsapp a una visita cara a
cara
segundo necesitamos comunicación real si
la persona con depresión quiere
desahogarse escuchen la y si la persona
con depresión no quiere hablar acompañen
la en silencio o mejor aún cuenten es
algo que para ustedes sea importante y
trascendental no una plática superficial
y les apuesto que en ese momento van a
distraer el cerebro de esa persona
y tercero contacto con la naturaleza
saquen a esta persona aunque sea el
patio de la colonia
los seres humanos necesitamos luz las
personas con depresión necesitan
vitamina d
finalmente quiero pedirles dos favores
por favor
métanse a clase de dibujo como yo
y segundo no sean como la la wta del
pasado y esperan a que les pase a
ustedes o que le pase a un ser querido
para que se encuentra de la importancia
del tema si hay alguien aquí que diga
puede no hablar a tu charla a bien pero
este tema no me viene a mí
si tú usas esa persona te quiero decir
que una de cada cinco personas va a
padecer depresión así que si no sos tú
va a ser un ser querido o el que está a
la par de tu silla pueden voltearlo a
ver
es importante también que sepamos la
siguiente estadística nacional
en el 2016 según la umh fuimos el tercer
país de latinoamérica con la tasa más
alta de suicidio y las cifras han venido
en incremento y ahora según un estudio
del doctor carlos carcas somos el país
número uno con la tasa más alta
en el 2017 según estadísticas del
ministerio de salud se registraban en el
salvador 6 mil casos de depresión cada
año sin embargo sólo el 1.1 del
presupuesto de salud era destinado a
salud mental y siempre en ese 2017 sólo
contábamos con 66 profesionales de salud
mental para toda el área pública ustedes
creen que dábamos abasto
según un estudio de la economista y bet
contreras al no tratar las enfermedades
mentales el salvador perdió 2.48 por
ciento del pib es decir 500 37 millones
de dólares perdidos
como cambiamos estas cifras estas cifras
no se cambian solas primero como
sociedad necesitamos educar sobre estos
temas desde los niveles básicos primero
porque según la oms s la mitad de los
trastornos mentales empiezan desde antes
de los 14 años y segundo porque la
segunda causa de muerte de los
adolescentes es el suicidio miren si a
mí en el colegio me hubieran enseñado
sobre salud mental así como me enseñaron
sobre biología sobre educación física y
si yo hubiera sabido identificar la
sintomatología de la depresión y
teniendo dos semanas esa sintomatología
alguien me hubiera dicho el aura tenéis
que buscar ayuda créanme que yo no
hubiera llegado tan lejos con la
depresión
segundo necesitamos educar en empresas
la depresión es la causa número uno de
discapacidad laboral a nivel mundial
y el 86% de las personas que padecen de
depresión está en su edad laboral y el
80% de las personas que describen su
salud mental como pobre dentro de una
empresa es debido a problemas laborales
nuestras cifras como se dieron cuenta
están mal y probablemente en nuestra
generación lo único que podamos hacer es
a paliar estos síntomas pero para las
futuras generaciones nosotros podemos
cambiar esta realidad ustedes si ustedes
que están sentados pueden salvar una
vida tal y como me la salvaron a mí con
educación con acompañamiento y con
empatía yo les hablo desde una situación
de privilegio porque yo tuve la fortuna
de tener a mi familia y a una red de
seres queridos de apoyo que conjunto
conmigo se educaron que fueron empáticos
conmigo y que me acompañaron durante
todo mi proceso sin embargo yo sé
que esto es un privilegio y me doy
cuenta cuando hablo con la mayoría de
personas que padecen depresión y me
dicen laura perdí a mi mejor amiga por
esto hola ahora mi familia fueran las
primeras personas que me discriminaron y
me aislaron
en los últimos tres años en el salvador
murieron mil 327 personas a causa de
suicidio eso quiere decir más de una
persona al día esto quiere decir que
ahora alguien en algún punto de nuestro
país va a morir a causa de la depresión
y va a perder la batalla ante esta
enfermedad
nosotros podemos cambiar estas cifras
quiero que vuelvan a pensar en la
primera pregunta que les hice al inicio
de la charla que es lo primero que se
les viene a la mente cuando escuchan la
palabra depresión y quiero que levanten
la mano las personas que cambiaron de
respuesta
que no nos tome los 4000 años que le
tomó a la sociedad cambiar la realidad
de la lepra para que nosotros también
nos la realidad de la depresión está en
nuestras manos podemos salvar vidas
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]